you were talking about the top guitars
of all time
Howard always likes to have the debate
Who falls on your list
well we have this uh you know we get
together at the rainbow every once in a
while myself Tom Morello a bunch of
guitar players and we have our Mount
Rushmore we call it Mount Rushmore
guitar players or any anything we do
best for rock singers but as far as
guitar players go for me it's always
been Paige Jimmy Page Brian May at the
top of that list for me is probably
Edward Van Halen the fourth's always
been very debatable you know uh
obviously Hendricks is one of the
greatest of all time but didn't
influence me as much uh growing up he
was a generation before I was so that
fourth spot I could throw Randy Rhodes
in there I could throw in you know
there's so many so many greats that uh
were just really really influence me so
I'll put Randy Rose in there as a fourth
one for today
foreign